في تكساس يفصل بين المكسيكيين على جانبي
الحدود مع امريكا ما هو اعمق واضخم من هذا
الجدار
فهناك من حالفهم الحظ وانتقلوا شمالا لارض
الاحلام كما يحلو لهم تسميتها وهناك من
يقف في طوابير انتظار او يبحث عن ثغره
دخولا غير قانونيه
الجمهوريه ماريه فلوريس هي اول سيده ولدت
في المكسيك ثم هاجرت الى امريكا لتصبح
نائبه في الكونغرس والان تسعى لاعاده
انتخابها ورسالتها هي اغلق الحدود
بسم اللهجتها المكسيكيه اثناء الحديث
بالانجليزيه لكنها تحرص على ابراز المظهر
المفضل للناخب الجمهوري وترديد الرساله
التي يحب الاستماع لها كما تحظى بشعبيه
بين ابناء عرقها من اللاتينيين
الجنس
[موسيقى]
المهاجرين القادم
طبعا
مكانه اصوات اللاتينيه الامريكيين مضمونه
للحزب الديمقراطي لكن في جنوب تكساس الوضع
ليس كذلك حيث يرى من يسكن المناطق
الحدوديه منهم ان سياسه بيضا للهجره
تنشروا الفوضى في اماكن معيشتها